quelle stratégie de déconfinement la
france va-t-elle adopté à partir du
fameux lundi 11 mai laquelle permettra
d'éviter la résurgence de ce comics 19
tout en épargnant les dégâts économiques
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct par skype à distance oblige
évidemment avec nicolas bailly ancien
député socialiste du pas de calais qui a
rejoint ensuite emmanuel macron il a été
l'un des premiers marcheurs il a depuis
repris ses distances conseiller
municipal de wingles à bonsoir monsieur
bailly merci d'être avec nous en face si
j'ose dire jean la capelle député
européen délégué national du
rassemblement national bonsoir à vous
aussi j'ai aussi d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors ce plan que
tout le monde attend après 11 mai
préparez concocté par edouard philippe
les grands lignes en ont été dévoilés
par emmanuel macron plutôt rassurant
pour vous eu monsieur nicolas bay moi
j'ai été rassuré par le fait qu'on ait
au moins un objectif en terme de date de
déconfinement ce qui se fait déjà dans
de nombreux pays on vient de le voir sur
votre antenne maintenant comme tout le
monde j'attends des explications
techniques sur les modalités de ce
déconfit manger quand j'ai compris comme
tout le monde puisse aider confinement
serait progressif et avec une certaine
restriction pour des catégories de
personnes j'attends maintenant de voir
des détails notamment sur le mas les
tests qui seront mises à disposition le
11 mai gens là la capelle ce
déconfinement le 11 mai ça vous paraît
viable mais je voudrais juste corriger
et rectifier un point de sémantique à
menen la con que je ne souhaite pas
défendre n'a jamais parlé de
déconfinement il a parlé d'une
prolongation de confinement jusqu'au 11
mai moi je suis pas certain que l'aide
du confinement on pourrait intervenir à
partir du 11 mai parce que je crois
qu'on n'arrête pas aujourd'hui les
capacités et les qualités et la locution
des macros en fête a été à l'exercice de
toutes les options et à l'exercice de
justification mais comment peut-on
aujourd'hui imaginer que le 11 mai
prochain
d'ailleurs la seule raison unique raison
pour laquelle cette date a été
défini c'est parce que nous avons ni le
matériel médical c'est à dire les
masques ni les tests au pouvoir demain
organisé une phase de déconfinement sera
belle tumen qu'emmanuel macron à jouer
le grand père noël en offrant dix sept
tonnes de matériel médical à la chine
je ne suis pas là pour bien des âmes en
revendiquer une antique générosité mais
quand le 24 février vous envoyer dix
sept tonnes de matériel mais les gars la
chine alors que vos propres vos propres
compatriotes sont en train de mourir
dans les hôpitaux je trouve ça assez
ambigu et deuxièmement il a aussi offert
par exemple samyn coffret de tests en
algérie alors qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
en pleine pénurie
non pas une pénurie mondiale une pénurie
francesca je voudrais quand même
rappeler parce qu'elle mêle nacre ont
dit nous sommes dans une pénurie
mondiale et comme dans tous les pays
nous souffrons non la france est la
sixième puissance mondiale économique
nous sommes le 46e pays en termes de
capacité à boire testés aux jeunes
compatriotes
c'est donc ridicule terrill c'est un
constat d'échec
un manque d'anticipation éminemment il
faut qu'on en tire les conclusions et
qu'on en tire les conclusions de demain
quand on est chef de l'état il faut
savoir gouverner
gouverner c'est prévoir emmanuel macron
dans l'apple les capacités nicolas bay
alors c'est ce que d'externat clocher la
capelle et avec madame le pen ces petits
veulent prévoir l'imprévisible
il ya quatre mois personne n'était au
courant de cette maladie et on ne savait
pas ce que donnerait cette maladie est
la dernière fois nicolas bay avait quand
même alerté le chef de l'état alors on
peut aller jusqu aux états-unis bill
gates mais même jérôme salomon pendant
la campagne avait évoqué la possibilité
d'une éventuelle épidémie
le professeur round donc bien sûr
professeur à l'odyssée mi février que
cette épidémie était une petite grippe
donc même les plus grands que tout le
monde appelle sur les bandes les
spécialistes aujourd'hui était très
sceptique sur cette maladie on a des
vidéos du professeur ajoute encore en
date
2 5 février il était très sceptique sur
l'arrivée de cette maladie en france et
il expliquait que ça serait que quelques
cas et puis je tiens à rappeler à
monsieur lagacé la dernière fois que en
france des ministres ont pris des
dispositions notamment madame bachelot
sur le hachana l'un des premiers partis
à avoir créé crier et critiqué mme
bachelot on a les vidéos monsieur la
capelle vous pouvez non faire tout ce
que vous voulez vous n'échapperez pas en
train de l'histoire
vous êtes chez les premiers à critiquer
ses stocks et ses stocks de masques
aujourd'hui oui il y a eu certainement
et il faudra en tirer toutes les
conséquences des dysfonctionnements sur
la distribution des masques et notamment
des conseils et des dysfonctionnements
logistiques aujourd'hui le pays produit
10 millions de masques par semaine sur
sa propre collection
il ya 90 millions de masques qui sont
arrivés cette semaine ce sera le double
la semaine prochaine des tests on en
fait 227 semaines on sera à plus de 500
milles à la fin de mois voilà la réalité
des chiffres
après on peut ne pas être d'accord sur
la méthodologie des tests
moi je suis de ceux qui pensent que
quand il faut attendre plusieurs jours
pour avoir le résultat d'un test ce test
il n'a pas de valeur oui il faut
réfléchir et on a des laboratoires
français qui sont en train de le faire
sur des tests salivaires par exemple qui
devrait bientôt être opérationnel et sur
lequel vous aurez qui qu'on trouve avec
très peu cher et sur lequel vous aurez
des résultats dans les vins 15 par
minute
très bien alors lui permettez moi de
vous répondre mais lorsque vous avez le
chef de l'état qui de manière solennelle
exprime une allocution disant nous
sommes en guerre
cela veut dire qu'ils se positionnent
permet aux chefs de guerre vous savez
quand vous êtes en guerre et on vous
apprend ça à l'école de guerre ce que
n'a pas fait d'ailleurs emmanuel macron
on prend les décisions rapidement j'ai
fait monsieur et messieurs je vous ai
pas coupé je vous aime a coupé mais
c'est très bien monsieur blé on nous
apprend pas à attendre et à suivre les
portes de colle ou les procédures
habituelles
il faut savoir à un moment quand on est
sur le front prendre décision
aujourd'hui
moi je constate juste monsieur b c'est
que dans les bouches du rhône et à
marseille
en effet nous avons des résultats
extrêmement positifs et un bilan
extrêmement positif sur le nombre
malade l'ombre de geri sur le combiné 19
mai vous savez mon propos n'était pas là
l'histoire ne dira exactement qui avait
raison mais il faut savoir moment je
crois prendre les décisions
quelquefois même si elle s'avère parfois
peut-être pas aussi efficace mais il
faut savoir un chef de guerre donc
j'amène ma con je pense ne porte pas le
le costume qu'il espérait porter mais il
annonce le 11 mai à aller confinement il
est reproduit le 11 mai la période de
confinement moi ce qui me pose un
problème c'est qu'il commence ce qu'il
ne fait aucun autre pays hormis deux ou
trois pays du nord de l'ordre
aucun pays aujourd'hui ont décidé de
commencer par l'ouverture des écoles des
crèches et et des lycées et là je crois
que c'est extrêmement grave parce que il
ne parle pas de désinfection de tous les
délices temps ils ne parlent pas ce
qu'on allait parler moyen d'équipements
de tout le personnel soignant qui râlent
aujourd'hui ils oublient que les enfants
sont en grande partie à saint-thomas tic
sur le virus du commis de mines il obéit
que 50% d'ailleurs les gens contaminés
ne se sont asymptomatiques grave
la ja oui c'est que je pense que après
la première lame d'épidémie à cause et
ans à cause des décisions des macros
nous risquons d'avoir la deuxième rave
alors effectivement vous venez de
résumer on vous donnera la parole
évidemment nicolas bay pour répondre
mais vous venez de résumer un petit peu
là la teneur du débat qui règne dans le
pays avec 7
ce retour à l'école pour bien le poser
je vous propose justement d'écouté
benjamins à marc professeur d'histoire
porte-parole de la cgt val-de-marne et
bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
qui donnent leur avis sur cette question
précisément et de qui se moque t-on
enfin soyons sérieux deux secondes on
est en train de nous dire à juste titre
qu'il faut se confiner depuis des
semaines
parce que le govic 19 nous entoure est
comment dire pèsent au dessus de nos
têtes comme une épée de damoclès et là
on nous explique que dans quoi trois
semaines il va falloir retourner en
cours à 35 mois je ma classe de
terminale l et à 30
à 35 dans trente mètres carrés en masque
sans avoir testé massivement puisque
emmanuel macron nous a expliqué que les
tests s'étaient pour ceux qui avaient
des symptômes
donc les porteurs asymptomatiques les
porter ça qu'ils sont très nombreux
parmi les jeunes n'auront pas été testés
et donc on va se retrouver ainsi
confinés dans un espace très réduit mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça certaines
personnes ont annoncé les enfants comme
vecteur de la mède
mais je vous rappelle que la plupart des
enfants sont possibles symptomatique
c'est direct peu de symptômes et que les
études qui ont été faites sur les
enfants sont montrent que les enfants
sécrète peu de virus donc c'est bien la
multiplicité des contacts que conte les
enfants entre eux qui guide cette
idéologie mais c'est pas une idéologie
qui était prouvée scientifiquement
dans le cadre du que vide donc non moi
ça m'inquiète qu'à moitié mais on n'a
pas de vraie réponse nicolas v et là on
a effectivement le résumé du débat en
france il ya ceux qui voient là refusé
de la chair à canon et d'autre des
scientifiques ils disent on n'a pas
prouvé que les enfants finalement s'en
sont dangereux je vous laisse répondre
alors déjà sur le syndicat me stresse
appétit que de la cgt je n'ai pas
entendu ni le ministre ni le président
dira que les classes reprendrait à 35
élèves et sans masque pour les
enseignants j'ai même entendu le
président dire que ce serait une rentrée
progressive avec l'assurance de tous les
moyens pour protéger le personnel
enseignant
comme il est fait dans les commerces
aujourd'hui les caissières qui sont
derrière leurs caisses dont qui les
supermarchés et qu'on peut remercier ici
il ya des mesures qui ont été prises des
murs de plexiglas des mesures de
distanciation avec les clients dans les
écoles
il se passera la même chose et ça se
passe déjà d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
puisque dans les écoles de ma commune on
reçoit les enfants des personnels
soignants dans des classes c'est dénigre
où les de la distanciation sociale qui
fédère déjà des retours d'expérience sur
deux des classes ouvert avec avec la
présence de la maladie est aujourd'hui
rien ne le prouve que les enfants
transmet plus la maladie et au contraire
on pense qu'ils transmettent - la
maladie que les adultes jardin
capelle pour vous c'était un choix
économique politique du président obama
croit au détriment de la santé du
sanitaire c'est ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui mais il est il est à
contrario de ce qui se passe dans les
autres pays d'europe même l'allemagne
d'ailleurs ne suit pas cet exemple là
bien évidemment il souhaiterait ouvrir
les crèches et les lycées au bois à
libérer les gens de manière à ce qu'ils
puissent aller travailler
alors attention intellectuellement n'est
pas idiote mais elle est elle et elle
est irresponsable irresponsable car
aujourd'hui c'est pas comme cela il faut
qu'on puisse voir équiper tout le monde
testé tout le monde n'a skié tout le
monde est aujourd'hui on a encore du
personnel soignant aujourd'hui qui
aujourd'hui se plaint parce qu'il n'a
pas du matériel pouvoir se protéger
on a un nombre de médecins deux
infirmières aides soignants ils sont
touchés par le kobe 19 dont on ne parle
même pas et d'ailleurs je ne parle même
pas dans les ehpad de ce drame qui est
d'un silencieux dans l'opinion publique
silencieux pas un certain nombre de
médias également car on a aujourd'hui
près 35 % de nos décès qui sont issus
des mais d'aider des ehpad plus tous les
gens qui meurent dans leur maison dans
leur domicile
ils sont pas comptabilisés ça me pose un
vrai vers un vrai problème
vous savez je crois que le gouvernement
en fait nous a montré une chose s'il ne
s'est pas anticipé il ne savait bien
avant il suffit et les chats permanence
d'une stratégiques défensives et non pas
offensive et rappelez vous allez
frontière quand le 24 janvier marine le
pen avait décidé il y avait demandé à ce
que nous fermions les frontières vous
avez dit à de repli ces macro qui
l'avait dit pas de repli sur soi même
le virus n'a pas de passeport très bien
et dès aujourd'hui finalement tous les
pays du monde ont fermé leurs frontières
et mais la lnah qu'on demande à ce que
l'europe ferme les frontières
européennes
mais pour des raisons idéologiques
dogmatique il ne veut pas fermer les
frontières nationales avec nos voisins
malheureux nos voisins malheureux comme
l'espagne et l'italie
qu'ils peuvent encore rentré aujourd'hui
avec toute liberté
alors qu'ils portent quelquefois pour
certains d'entre eux le virus donc nous
sommes pas prêts à les français certains
c'est le porte aussi peut-être gens-là
laquelle nicolas bay sur cette fermeture
des frontières vous souhaiteriez vous
voir les ce serait utile de fermer les
frontières de la france peut-être que
pour que chaque pays tout simplement
gère sa crise comme il l'entend je pense
que la fermeture des frontières la
maladie circulent la maladie n'a pas de
fort elle ne connaît pas les frontières
et que la ferme de nos frontières
cette idée doit maîtriser les pays et
certains pays qui ont fermé leurs
frontières
dès le début notamment la russie a fermé
sa frontière très rapidement être la
chine la russie est aujourd'hui
extrêmement affecté aussi par le virus
alors que sa frontière est et permet
c'est pas la russie vient de renvoyer 40
chinois a affecté en chine
qu'est ce qui est en train de créer un
deuxième foyer pandémique avec nicolas
bel bien sûr mais monsieur b monsieur b
monsieur public je ne dis pas la maladie
sir toll collect monsieur b c'est bien
là je crois le super g jeudi de la
frontière à pied sur les frontières les
frontières ne permettent pas de temps
pêcher le virus de rentrer dans un pays
je n'ai jamais dit cela en revanche ça
permet de contrôler et de réguler
d'affaiblir et bien sûr de faire en
sorte que vous proposiez beaucoup moins
le virus
et ça c'est un point important sur
lequel pour les raisons dogmatiques
l'europe n'a pas vu le faire elle change
d'avis aujourd'hui
et dernière chose et là je le dis de
manière politique
quand j'entends et de mâcon dans une
allocution qui dit je vais annuler les
dettes que nous avons les dettes que
l'afrique a à notre rencontre je trouve
ça extrêmement généreux et je ne remets
pas anglais sur la générosité mais
j'aimerais que le fasse d'abord pour nos
entreprises nos artisans tous ceux qui
sont le poumon de l'emploi en france
les restaurants des mes petits
commerçants qui sont en train de crever
c'est un e
il faut pas décaler le gouvernement
n'est pas très généreux pour vous aux
gens là
la capelle sont des milliards de chance
mais chômage partiel mis en place très
tôt
écoutez c'est le choix de leur ciel dit
très bien mais excusez moi j'ai un
certain nombre d'amis ou de
connaissances dans mon entourage qui me
disent j'ai fait ma demande auprès de la
direccte de mon département
on a reçu c'est le chômage technique
pour mais pour mes employés alors qu'ils
sont dans une petite pme sans activité
donc c'est à la fin de la foire contre
allez vous semble avoir aujourd'hui
c'est son job saisonnier pour aider
merci on ira enfin j'espère qu'on ira
bien sûr à la fin d'un positif mais
d'abord au lieu d'annuler une dette des
pays africains d'abord d'abord annuler
les dettes de nos entreprises françaises
et au moins on aura été on aura été
papillotes six a déjà tant de nous alors
nicolas v le mot de la fin ça me plaît
je pense que monsieur la capelle n'a pas
dû bien écouter le président bak rond
lors de son intervention puisque lors de
la première intervention il avait parlé
de report de charges pour les
entreprises les petits commerces et là
il affirmant parler de dallas il a
clairement parler d'annulation de charge
il a parlé d' annulation de charges et
les charges vont être annulées pour les
petits commerces et aujourd'hui le
conseil des ministres a réouvert une
enveloppe supplémentaire pour venir en
aide aux pme et aux tpe et y aura des
mesures spécifiques qui seront prises
pour la restauration et le tourisme
non non leur annulation de charge on
pourra en reparler la capelle à lula
sont charges qui sont ces annulations de
charge qui a été dit dans le discours
merci à tous les deux nicolas bay
jenlain à cappelle merci beaucoup
d'avoir un jeu du débat à distance merci
à vous